قائد عسكري ميداني في ميليشيا الروسيه ان
الجيش الاوكراني يدمر منشات البنيه
التحتيه خصوصا الطرق والجسور في مدينه
باخموت وما حولها واضاف القائد العسكري في
فاجنر ان القوات الاوكرانيه تدمر البنى
التحتيه في محاوله لعرقله تقدم قواته كما
قالت وسائل اعلام روسيه ان الجيش
الاوكراني دمر الجسر الذي يربط ضفتي نهر
بخمودكا ويمر من وسط مدينه بخموت وجسرا
اخر على قناه مائيه باتجاه مدينه جاسوفيار
المجاوره
على الصعيد المتصل نقل مراسل الجزيره عن
مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه قولها ان ميليشيا
فاجنر احرز التقدم الجزئيا في محاولاتها
للتقدم نحو قريه خروموفا على المحور
الشمالي لمدينه باخموت واوضحت المصادر ان
قريه هرموفا ما زالت تحت سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه والتي تمر منها اخر الطرق
الموصله الى مدينه بخموت واشارت المصادر
الى ان المعركه الضاريه مستمره على
المحورين الشرقي والجنوبي للمدينه
وقالت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه في بيان
القوات الروسيه قصفت 15 بلده في محيط
باخموت وصدت خمسه وثمانين هجوما روسيا على
محاور القتال في اقليم دومباس شرقي البلاد